♪ (music) ♪
Flutter and Dart
are asynchronous by nature.
With Dart's Futures, you can manage IO
without worrying
about threads or deadlocks.
But how do you build widgets
when a Future is involved?
Enter FutureBuilder,
the future of handling, well, futures.
FutureBuilder lets you easily determine
the current state of a future
and choose what to show
while the data's loading
and when it's available.
Start by giving FutureBuilder a future,
and then a builder.
But make sure to check the state
of the future with connectionState
and display an appropriate widget
when your future is busy.
Finally, it's good practice to check
that no error has occurred
while your future was resolving.
There are other ConnectionStates
that you can use.
For more info on FutureBuilder
and all the other Flutter widgets,
head on over to flutter.io.
♪ (music) ♪